the negotiations could drag on for
months effectively shutting Hollywood
down here's what the strike is all about
and what it can mean for the future
after weeks of build up sagafra was
caught a strike taking its 160 000 film
and TV actors out of the studios and
into the streets to demand better
conditions and compensation coupled with
the ongoing writer's Guild of America
strike now on its 73rd day this
constitutes the first Joint Strike
between the groups since 1960. the
strike will begin at midnight tonight
and all of us union members leadership
and staff will be out on the picket
lines tomorrow morning tension between
union members and Studio Executives had
risen in the days leading up to the
official announcement ever since initial
negotiations for new long-term contract
fell through just hours before the
decision was made public Disney CEO Bob
Iger called the possibility of a strike
very disruptive during an appearance on
cnbc's Squawk Box like the wga sagafter
is striking for a number of improvements
including General compensation and
raises for working actors with visions
the residual payment model in the
streaming era and limitations on AI
usage moving forward Studios and
Hollywood Executives claim to have made
Fair offers for a new contract to the
union but sag after leaders say these
offers were far from Equitable the union
has cited a growing disconnect between
higher ups and rank and file working
actors which has led to untenable
working conditions for actors outside
the Hollywood Elite to imagine something
coming in and not only like displacing
you but just placing you with your own
work that's what's at stake speaking in
the wake of the strike announcement sag
after a president Fran Drescher said
that the negotiations with the alliance
of motion picture and television
producers were insulting making
connections to the larger ongoing labor
movement Across America in recent months
what happens here is important what's
happening to us is
evening
across all
fields of Labor Joshua went on to say I
cannot believe it quite frankly how far
apart we are on so many things how they
plead poverty that they're losing money
left and right when giving hundreds of
millions of dollars to their CEOs but at
some point you have to say no we're not
going to take it anymore according to
Drescher the decision to strike was
universally supported by membership
saying we came together in strengthened
solidarity and unity with the largest
strike authorization vote in our Union's
history under the conditions of the
strike no union members will be allowed
to work on film or TV sets promote
currents upcoming or previous projects
or attend official events in partnership
with the studios like Comic-Con that
means no premieres either in fact
emphasize on the cast of Oppenheimer
walked away from their London red carpet
hours before the announcement The Jig Is
Up you cannot keep being dwindled and
marginalized and disrespected and
Dishonored a joint strike with both
sagafra and the wga hasn't occurred in
over 60 years the last time both unions
walked out the entertainment industry
looked wildly different than it does now
which makes the coming months hard to
predict if the writer's Guild strike as
far as any indication of what's to come
though it could be a long road Drescher
and other leaders from both unions have
made it clear that their intentions are
large to reset a growing disparity that
has allowed Studios to profit while
leaving working actors and writers
struggling to make a full-time living
some industry veterans have been sharing
their actual compensation for major
projects in recent days like She-Hulk
writer Cody Ziegler who received a
residual check for his work on the
series hit Daredevil episode for just
396 dollars at this point the studios
seem dug in for the near future ready to
fall back on reality TV and other
non-unium projects to fill airtime in
May ABC announced a full slave devoid of
new scripted programming but it seems
unlikely that the unions are willing to
give up much ground Drescher used their
speech to boil down the situation to its
heart that the Hollywood business model
has changed so fundamentally in recent
years that the SAG after a contract
needs fundamental changes to work with
the net you share the wealth because you
cannot exist without us
foreign